TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your
first update in 2018
about the coolest
developer news from Google
in the last couple of weeks.
Configuring and maintaining
IP-based firewall rules
is a complex and
manual process that
can lead to unauthorized
access if done incorrectly,
which is why we're
excited to announce
the support for
service accounts.
They simplify the application
management lifecycle
by providing
mechanisms to manage
authentication and
authorization of applications.
More details and
screenshots are on the post.
You can now attach NVIDIA
K80 and NVIDIA P100 GPUs
to Preemptible VMs
for 50% cheaper
than GPUs attached to
on-demand instances.
Preemptible GPUs will be
a particularly good fit
for large-scale machine learning
and other computational batch
workloads as customers can
harness the power of GPUs
to run distributed
batch workloads
at predictably
affordable prices.
Ways to get started
are on the post.
OK, this week is short on
news from our platform teams.
So if you're looking for
some more reading material,
may I recommend some
2017 recap posts,
including a look back at
the most read Google Play
posts on Medium in 2017,
the end of year recap
extravaganza from
the Firebase team,
and some of the most popular
Google Cloud Platform
product announcements, white
papers, and how-tos in 2017.
These are all linked in
the description below.
Please enjoy and remember
to look back here
every Friday for your
update on all the coolest
developer news from Google.
Oh, and please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of The Developer Show.
If you'd like to catch some
of our highlights from 2017,
check them out right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]